All right, guys, so in this lecture, I'm going to talk about the market maker model second
distribution entry model, okay, this model has to be has to have the like the best wind
rate possible.
This is like a plus entry set up a plus model that you can use and become an independent
trader.
After watching this model and understanding this model entry model, you will not need
anything else, okay, I guarantee you.
So you have to watch this video very carefully.
Now as we know, the market maker model is that we have first consolidation, then we
have the second and the third, the second, the third consolidation is not necessary,
okay.
So now these two consolidations are also called accumulation zones, okay.
So we have accumulation here and we have accumulation here, we have consolidation here.
So now let's suppose that this key level is a daily external liquidity, right?
Once price takes out the external liquidity, right, we let's say this is the fairly gap,
this low here of the consolidation is our fairly gap or drawn liquidity internal liquidity,
right.
Once we get a market structure shift, right, once we have this shift in the market structure,
normally we would take our entry from this fairly gap or an auto block here and target
this level.
But in this second distribution model, listen what we have to do.
So we must have a higher high, high low, higher high, right, into the key level price
takes out liquidity, then we have a market structure shift, lower, lower low, lower high
after market structure shift, then we have lower low, lower high, lower low, right.
So once we have like a lower low, lower high, lower low, and we also have a market structure
shift.
So market structure shift, pullback, another low, low.
Once we have this, now we are waiting for a continuation purge.
Now what is that?
We have to wait for price to take out some form of lower high, okay.
So let's say there's a lower high here, what's going to happen?
Price takes out this lower high, and then you wait for a shift in market structure or
a break of structure, right, like that.
Once you have another break of structure, you wait for another pullback, you wait for
another break of structure, right, a fractal break of structure.
And then if there's a family gap here, perfect.
If there's no family gap here, you look at this leg here.
If there's a family gap, that is going to be your second distribution entry model.
And that is going to just push the price aggressively towards your take profit level.
Once you get this type of setup, trust me guys, there's like, I guarantee you, you're
going to win that trade, most of the time, okay.
So let's talk about this again, right?
So it's going to take some time maybe for you to understand.
We have a higher high, a higher high, we have the external liquidity taken out, right?
Once that is taken out, okay.
So here's the thing.
You don't have to look for these highs on the daily timeframe.
Once you have the key level taken out on the daily, you then drop to one hour and then
identify this setup.
So price takes out the external liquidity, we then wait for a market structure shift,
right?
And then we wait for the pullback, that's create lower low, lower high, lower low.
We then have another break of structure.
Once we have the break of structure, we wait for any lower high, any lower high to be purged.
Once you have a purge on that, you wait, you wait again for that double break of structure
pattern.
So you're going to have lower low, breaks the structure, somewhere here, somewhere here,
or this whole level.
And then you have a pullback and then the structure breaks again.
Once you have that, look for a fairly gap or an auto blog, you put your entry here and
guys, the next thing you know, your trade is boom, right into this level.
I need you to watch this again and again.
I will show you the examples as well, but I need you to watch it again and again.
This is like the best I see concepts that I'm teaching you right now.
And if you can understand this, oh my God, bro, I don't even know.
You will become like an independent trader.
That's pretty much it.
You don't need anything else.
Okay.
So I'm going to show you some examples and then I'll end the video, like the whole lecture.